sadie robertson is officially a new mama
i've never been more excited my whole
life honestly
the former duck dynasty star and her
husband christian huff have welcomed
their first child together
a baby girl it's just been really
special and a great experience
the 23 year old motivational speaker
announced her pregnancy in october 2020
with an adorable sonogram post
we are expecting a little child a little
child
and ever since sadie and christian have
shared milestone moments and photos of
her growing baby bump
along the way including this one where
the couple recreated this image of
sadie's parents
when they were expecting the pair has
been together since 2018 when they first
met on a trip to florida match made in
heaven mass made in heaven
amazing almost a year later christian
popped the question on sadie's family
farm in louisiana
you won't be on fiance for long we're
getting married
five months later the duo tied the knot
in the same spot they got engaged
it was like the coolest moment of my
life it really was
e.t caught up with sadie in march 2020
she opened up about
what it's like being a newlywed in
quarantine
for us we've actually had a lot of fun
we've learned a lot about each other
and which is funny because we live
together but you really live together
now you know
so we've learned a lot about each other
congrats to the happy couple on
welcoming their new bundle of joy you